[음악]
네 안녕하세 빌사남 있니다 이른
아침부터 머리도 하고 강연을 하러
가고 있는데 오늘 강연은 좀 특별한
분들 대상으로 합니다 고등학생들
대상으로 강의를 진행할 예정이고 제가
알고 있기로는 최소한 만 명 정도
오는 거 같아요 굉장히 큰 행사고
이제 막 고등학교를 졸업하는 친구들이
강연을 듣고 좀 힘을 냈으면
좋겠습니다 실력으로 인정받을 수 있는
사회가 됐으면 좋겠어요 고졸도 뭔가
스펙이 되는 지금까지 좀 사업하면서
이렇게 좀 생각했던 것들 그런 것들을
좀 많이 설명해 줄 예정입니다 일단
가기 전에 밥을 먹죠 뭐 먹고
싶어요 뭐 대학 없네
맞아요
[음악]
고등학생한테 처음 강의하는 기분은
어떠세요데 그 전에도 했었어요 진짜요
예 그니까 이제 작은 학교에서 아
작은 학교에서네 그때 2013년도에
처음 했었나 최근에는 안 했는데 되게
오랜만에 하는 거 같고 그리고 이렇게
큰 규모는 또 처음이에요 그 많은
고등학생 분들 중에 제 얘기를 듣고
한 명이라도 좀 이렇게 진짜 좀
인생이 바뀌었다고 하면 진짜 너무
뿌듯할 것 같아요 저 그 중고등학생들
강의할 때 제가 2013년도에
했잖아요 나중에 이제 취업할 때도 막
연락이 와요 그 강의 너무 잘
들었었다 연락받고 그러면 되게 뿌듯한
거 같아요 오늘도 만약에 강의했는데
나중에 이제 5년 뒤 10년 뒤에 또
만날 수도 있잖아요 사업 파트너로
만날 수도 있고 우리 회사에 또
들어올 수도 있고 저는 되게 좀 이런
기회가 올 때 무조건 하려고
합니다네
[음악]
고등학생을 되게 오랜만에 보는 거
같아요 고등학교 다니게 한 10
13년
[음악]
14년전 일단 느낀 점은 이렇게 많은
고등학생들 진짜 오래만에 보는데 되게
좀 낯설고 애들이 엄청
크네요가 고등학생 같지가 제가 항상
강할 때 조금 연세가 있으신 분들
만나다가 이렇게 좀 젊은 친구들
만나서 생소하긴
합니다 몇 년생인지 물어볼까요
2005년생
2005년생 나이 차게
많이 사실 저도 젊은 편인데 많이
늙었나 한 4 50분 정도 뒤에
강인데 좀 그냥 편안하게 동생한테
얘기하듯이 잘하고 보겠습니다 일단
뵐게요
자기 속에서 이렇게 쓰네요 성장 과정
그다음에 성격의 장단점 병원 및 기타
활동상 지원 도기 한 명만 들었으면
좋겠다 한 명이라도 잘 들었으면
좋겠다 강의 끝나고 한번 인터뷰를 따
보겠습니다 강의가 얼마 안 남았는데
수감이
어어 아무 생각 일단
시작하면은 시작하면은 그래도 할거라고
예상을 하는데 매번 강의할 때마다 좀
이렇게 항상 긴장은 하는 거 같아요
최대한 긴장 안 하려고 그간 잡생각을
많이
합니다 아니 애들이 진짜 엄청
[음악]
크네요 지금부터 수적 고조 참스
주제로
대표님의 강의를 시작
하겠습니다 다 주제로 강의를 하게 된
김윤수 대표라고 합니다
[음악]
고맙습니다 그래서 제서 저희가 공
건물을 이제 공사하고 저는 그
뉴욕에서 성공하고 싶어요이 자리
없었단
말이에요 제일 잘 보이는 데다 매일
봐보세요네 혹시 뭐 질문 있으신 분
계세요 질문 일단 첫 번째로 살면서
읽으신 책 중에 가장 인상 깊으셨던
책 이 궁금하고 그리고 두 번째로
군대는 빨리 가는게 좋을지 여쭤보고
싶고 성공에 이르기까지 가장 중요한
마인드가 궁금합니다 아직 성공은 하진
않았지만 항상 저는 잘될 때를
생각했어요 그니까 5년 뒤에 이렇게
돼 있을 거다라는 상상을 항상 했어요
뭐 예를 들어서 내가 어떻게 창업을
해서 지금 뭐 뉴욕에서 내가 부동산
중개업을 하고 있을 거다라고 맨날
상상하거나 성공했을 때 모습을
매일같이 상상했었던 거 같아요 그리고
군대는 빨리
가세요 어 빨리 가야 돼요 그리고
책은 제가 존경하는 분들이 분이 이제
그 정주영 회장님이 너 이거 해봤어
아는 문구 아세요 저 정주영 회장님
되게
[음악]
존경하거나
삼국지 많이 왔어요 삼국지 삼국지에서
배우는게 많아요 목표에 이동하면서 그
과정이네 하루하루가 너무 찬데 그걸
어떻게
이겨내는지 제가 아까 계속 말씀드린
목표가 일단 있잖아 목표 목적지가
있어야지 내가 아무리 힘들어도 버거요
근데 대부분 다 포기하는 거는 목표가
없는 거예요
그냥 그래서 저는 아무리 힘들어도
목표를 보면서 견뎌냈어요 그리고 나는
잘거다 맨날 생각하고 근데 그런게 다
어서
왔냐면 도전인 공인중개사 자격증을
취득할 때 왔어 아 나도 하면
되는구나 아 전자 계획과 꼴등도 하면
되는구나 거기서 많이 느꼈단 말이에요
그래서 여러분들도 일단은 목표를
세우고 작은 거부터 일단 하나씩 잃어
보세요 그럼 자신감이 생겨요 아 나도
하면 되는구나 질문 주셔서 너무
감사드리고 오늘 좀 제가 여러 얘기를
하긴 했는데이 자리를 일어나면 기억이
안 나실 거예요 제가 계속 목표를
말씀드렸지만 목표를 좀 세워 보시고
작은 거부터 좀 해보세요 여러분들
나이는 사실 그냥 뭘 해도 돼요 뭘
해도 아시겠죠 자신감을 가지세요 저도
했잖아요 저 아무것도 없는데 저 공부
잘하지도 않단 말이에요 하니까
됐잖아요 17시간씩 공부하니까
됐잖아요 하면 돼요 다 오늘 강의
들어주셔서 감사하고요네 좋은 시간
보세요 감사합니다 강의를 듣고 느낀
점이 있나요 정말 멋있게 성공을
이루신 분들의 성장 과정을 직접 듣고
저 역시도 그 과정을 듣고 성공을
이름에 있어서 참고하고 그들이 먼저
느끼고 실패한 조언들을 받아서 시간을
아끼고 성공으로 더 명확히 달려갈 수
있어서 좋은 거 같습니다 젊은이
채고운 거 같아요 잘 마무리가
됐습니다네 그래서 시간이 어떻게
가는지 몰랐어요네 해줄 얘기가 너무
많은데 잘 마무리 된 거 같습니다
저도 강의하면서 집중해서 듣는
학생들도 좀 있어 가지고 되게
고맙기도 했고 나이가 어리긴 하지만
그래도 그렇게 들기도 하고 뭐 영상도
이렇게 찍어서 남기더라도
그분들이 나중에 좀 어떻게 될까 좀
궁금하기도 합니다 학생들 대상으로
강의하는 것도 정기적으로 좀 해야 될
거 같습니다 그래서이 영상을 보고
계신 혹시 어 고졸이신 뭐 학생분이
계신다면 자신감을 갖고 진짜 이것저것
다 도전해보셨으면 좋겠습니다 고등학생
아니면 이제 갓 만약에 뭐
20살이라고 하면은 뭘 해도 돼요네
뭘 해도 되고 계속 얘기하는데 뭘
해도 될라입니다 난 안 될거다 난요
정도다 이렇게 그런 생각하지 마시고
어떤 걸 도전하셔도 됩니다 고절 출신
여러분들이 많이 성공하는 사례들이 좀
나왔으면 좋겠습니다 고조 학생들
응원하고 오늘 영상은 여기서 마치도록
하겠습니다 안녕히세요